[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN WEISS: Hi.
My name is Ben.
[APPLAUSE]
And today I'm here
to talk to you
about modularization of your
app and Android Instant Apps.
I work in London on the
Android Developer Relations
team as an engineer, and
I spend a fair amount
of my time working
with the Instant Apps
team and the early
access partners,
as well as on samples.
So at Google I/O 2016, we
introduced Android Instant
Apps, and we then closely worked
with a set of early access
partners and made the SDK
generally available this year
at Google I/O.
So everyone now can
build an Instant App.
Android Instant Apps follows
three main principles.
That's discoverability,
performance, as well as
security and privacy.
Today I'm going to take you
through these key principles,
and let's get started.
First off, discoverability--
discovering an app sometimes
can take a little bit of time.
What happens every
now and then is
you find an app
either by browsing
in the Play Store, or
somebody recommends it,
or you literally just search for
apps and specifically find it,
either with the Pixel
Launcher or in another way.
Well, that's cool, but
then you install it,
and sometimes you
forget about it.
And through one or
the other mechanism,
you rediscover the app,
and then you use it.
That's the trodden
path that developers
have to deal with so
far, and users actively
have this as well.
It's really great.
It works well, but we
can do a little bit
better than that as well.
So what happens is
there is basically
a funnel from the
user finds the app.
Then they actually read
through everything,
and they decide to
install the app.
And in the end, they use
the app in a longer time.
So you've got a proper
retention rate on that.
Well, like I said,
there is quite a lot
of friction in
that, and we figured
there has to be a better
way to deal with this.
And we wanted to reduce this.
So let's take a look at the
process with Instant Apps.
Say Joy sends me a
link to BuzzFeed.
I'm like, oh, cool, I wanted
to see something about cooking.
And I click the link.
What then happens is
the app, part of the app
gets downloaded instantly, and
I have the native app experience
on my device.
No friction whatsoever.
I don't have to install the app.
It's done automatically
with the magic that the Play
Services provide, as well as
the magic that's happening
on your device with that.
Simple.
So we launched with 50
early access partners
from across a multitude of
industries, and like I said,
this SDK is now generally
available to every developer.
And the amount of devices that
are enabled for Android Instant
Apps recently has passed
half a billion devices.
That is quite a lot, and
it's still working upwards
trajectory, so it's going to
be even more in the future.
Well, that's all cool
and stuff, but how
does it work from a
developer's perspective?
Because I take that many of you
in here are Android developers
and want to know
how you do that.
So let's take a look at
the high level developer's
overview of how this works.
Basically, your app is
just a monolithic thing.
That's the one thing that
gets installed on the device.
That's the one thing you
actually have to care about.
That was the old world, and
that's the installable app
world.
That's fine.
But let's take a
closer look at that.
Basically, your app consists
of multiple features,
and those features sometimes
have commonalities.
And you can take all
those commonalities
and refactor them
in multiple modules.
Say you've got the Feature
A, you've got a Feature B.
And those commonalities, you
put them in a base feature
that those other
features rely on.
Still, the build output
for your installable app
will be one APK with all
those features combined,
and that's the same thing that
will happen on the device.
So you have this one APK that
gets installed on the device.
Within the Instant App
world, what will happen,
instead of getting
an APK, you get
a zip file with a
multitude of APKs
in there, which then can be
uploaded to the Play Store.
And the Play Store
decides, depending
on the length of user
clicks, which part of that
will be installed on the
device, while not hogging
too much of the bandwidth
that is available,
as well as space on the device.
So let's see how this
works on a device.
When you click on
Feature A, what happens
is the base module
gets installed,
as well as the Feature A. When
a user, on the other hand,
clicks through the sideways
on Feature B, what happens is
only Feature B gets installed.
But if the user clicks
first on Feature A,
then works his way through to
the next feature, both of those
can be installed, so everything,
every part of your app
can be installed on the
device at the same time.
So the users won't really
notice the difference, other
than they don't have to
download the app manually and go
through the whole search
and discovery process.
So to recap that, you've got
a more fine-grained control
over features with
cleaner edges.
And with that
process, you also can
decrease the size of your
app, which is good for users
as well.
And with the new
Gradle plugins, you
improve your build
times, as well as,
as a side effect, you improve
the testability of your app
and can improve the architecture
with that as well, which
will increase your
velocity during development
in the middle and long run.
In the end, it doesn't
really matter what you have.
It's one app, be it before it's
an installed app, as an Instant
App, or afterwards.
So you can essentially
run the same code,
and don't have to
rewrite everything.
There is some refactoring
involved, though,
but I'll come to that
a little bit later.
Let's take a look
at the requirements
and the specifications for
Instant Apps on your device
as well as on a couple of
tools that we can use on that.
So it's available to devices
running Lollipop and above,
which is already a lot.
And with Android Studio
3.0, we introduced a set
of tools and plug-ins
that developers
can use to make Android
Instant Apps work for them.
There is the Instant Apps
SDK that you can download.
Also, there is new
Gradle plug-ins
for feature modules,
which I just mentioned,
as well as for the
Instant App module, which
we will take a look under
those a little bit later.
Also, there's the
App Links Assistant,
which allows you to output
a file that can easily
upload to your server
to make the matching
possible between the
local app and your domain.
Also, the emulator supports
Android Instant Apps.
All you have to do is set
up a test account on that,
and you can easily
work with Instant Apps
without having to have a
device that is enabled with it.
Also, there's a refactoring
tool, which allows you
to, for example,
take one activity,
click on the refactoring
action, and instead
of having to go through this
refactoring step by step
manually, you can
just say, I want
to refactor this into
a module, and that
with all the code that's
associated with it, as well
as the resources, can be
put into a separate module.
And then you can start working
with the couple of things
that you have to do to make your
app accessible as an Instant
App.
So yeah, what do
we actually have
to do to get there, to
make my app instant?
So like I said, there might
be some refactoring involved,
if you already have
an existing app,
depending on the
structure of your app.
Let's take a look at
a couple of things
that you definitely will have
to do without going in too deep
into depth of the
refactoring of the app.
One of the things
that you have--
every app has is a
settings.gradle file,
if you build with Gradle.
Otherwise, there is
currently no support
on other built systems for that.
But for the settings.gradle
file, all you have to do
is delete your currently
existing app module,
and then replace that
with base modules that you
have refactored as well
as the feature modules,
and have one new module that's
the installed app, which
basically correlates to
your existing app module
that you had before, and add a
new module for the Instant App.
The only two relevant
modules for the device output
are the installed and
the Instant App module.
But let's take a look
through step by step.
First off, the base module.
In order to make sure that the
base module works as intended,
you have to mark it
as a base feature.
That's the only thing you have
to do specifically for that.
Also, apply the
feature plug-in to have
it either output an APK, if you
work in the Instant App world,
or a library, if you work
in the installed app world.
For the other features that are
depending on the Instant App
module, what you will have
to do is you just say,
this feature is implementing
the base feature.
Also, you can have
your dependencies scope
directly to the features
that are using them.
And I highly recommend
scoping them as narrowly
as you possibly can
in order to avoid
having a massively bloated
base module in there.
On the installed
app, what do you
have to do is you still
have the application plug-in
that you already had.
And then, within
your dependencies,
you have the dependencies
on those feature modules
that you had before.
Very similar for
the Instant App,
you just apply a
different plug-in.
And that defines
which output you
will get-- either one
single APK or a zip
file with a multitude of APKs.
Also, in your
manifest, there has
to be some changes
that you have to make.
So if you're wondering,
is my app actually
a good use case for
Instant App, well, yes.
And you can think
about it if your app
is addressable via URL.
Then this is the use case
for an Instant App as well.
In order to make that all
happen and to make it work,
you have to have
an activity that
has the Android Auto-Verify
set to true in order
to have the app links available,
and you have to set the Action
View and category of
browsable, and your default
activity that you already
have has to have the default
category as well.
Then you associate your
URL to your activity.
And for your default
activity, what you have to do
is give it some metadata
to have a default
URL that it can fall back
to if none of the other ones
is applicable.
Also, one of the cool things
that we introduced with Oreo
is a new sandbox version.
With that sandbox, we tightened
security and make sure
that we can migrate user
data from the Instant App
to the installed app.
More on that later.
The next principle of Android
Instant App is performance.
So what does that
mean for a developer?
So the main question
is, how do I
get from having this
click to getting output
and getting the app
installed instantly?
What does that take?
One of the things that's
basically-- that's
how you have to constrain
your app in size.
You have to make it as
small as you possibly
can in order to transfer
it as quickly as possible
over the wire.
So that's kind of
scary, because we
are factoring everything
and making everything
as small as possible.
It takes a lot of time.
There's a couple
of things involved.
But actually, it's
not that hard.
And while you're developing,
there's no size constraint.
So you can easily
just work with it
from just having those
changes in the Gradle files
without having to limit
yourself and without having
to send your app on a diet.
That's really cool for the
first refactoring efforts,
and it's also really, really
helpful for the pitches
to the team and for your product
owners and product managers
to actually show them,
hey, this would happen
if our app was an Instant App.
You can show this to
them on their device
and take it from there.
When you've taken the
next steps towards that
is when you upload
your app to the Play
Store for the first time
to a development track,
there's a download bundle size
limit of 10 megabytes, which
is still quite generous, because
that's not your whole app,
but just the download bundle.
When you move onto alpha beta
production, what then happens
is you will be constrained
to four megabytes
per downloadable bundle.
So that's 1,024 to power
of 2 times the megabytes
that you have, but what's
with the bundle size?
Bundle size basically
means if your base bundle
is quite large--
say three megabytes-- you could
have features on top of that,
which each are one megabyte.
That, effectively, gives
you six megabytes on device.
But if you split those
two features that
were combined into two
different features,
you would gain another megabyte.
Similar, if you can
slim down your base APK,
your base feature module,
all your other modules
can grow in size as well.
I don't recommend just growing
it for the sake of growing it,
but you have ways to actually
play around with that limit
a little bit more effectively.
So just to recap, stay
under four megabytes.
Yes, under.
The lower you can
go, the better it
is, because it improves
your user's experience
from getting from the click
to the installed application.
So let's take a look
at a couple of tools
that we offer to make this
easier for you as developers.
One of them is the APK Analyzer.
Some of you might be
already familiar with it,
especially if you just watched
the session earlier today
here at Google Developer Days.
This gives you good insights of
where your kilobytes are spent
and works with installable apps
as well as with Instant Apps.
So we just dropped the
Instant App zip in there,
and you can see which of your
modules takes the most size,
and you can have all the
insights that you want to have.
That's really great.
Also, in order to make
sure that you divide
your app into modules
easier and to have
the output properly modularized,
there's configuration splits.
Well, that works with either
screen density or the processor
architecture type if
you have native code,
as well as the user's language.
The cool thing about
that is that you
don't ship all the resources
and all the drawables
and everything to the
user, but the experience
is tailored to
the user's device.
So an HDPI device
with English language
would only get HDPI resources
and the English language.
Same accounts for
processor architecture.
So how do you enable that?
That's straightforward.
Within your built
Gradle file, it's
able to generate pure splits,
then set the density to true.
That should be enabled.
Depending on whether you
have native code or not,
the API part is
essential as well,
and you can split
all the languages
into your different feature,
into the different modules
as well.
What will happen is
that all of those splits
are being generated, and they
will reside in their own APKs.
And the Play Store decides
this will be shipped,
and the other ones--
well, just don't take
up space over the wire
or on the user's device.
Also, the further you reduce
your APK size, what you can do
is use code minification,
resource shrinking, Proguard,
or other things that we
talked about at Google I/O
or at other conferences
already like using WebP.
Make sure that your
images aren't too big.
Make sure that you remove
all the unused resources.
But that has been covered in a
wide variety of words already.
So how does it work?
Again, just for your
release build type,
because in development,
it doesn't really
matter that much, you can minify
it, can shrink your resources,
or can use your Proguard
files for the modules
that you're working with.
Be aware that you
have to have the API
surfaces of your feature
modules excluded from Proguard
so that they don't
get obfuscated,
because otherwise, the
modules can't really
communicate with one another.
Also, one of the
things is that you
don't have to have everything
as an Instant App immediately,
if you consider working
with Instant Apps.
There may be features that are
more suitable within your app
to become an Instant
App than others.
And your users will
encounter that boundary
in that case, which
basically means
that you have to have an
installer for it at some point.
These are two examples
where you can have them.
There's different ways as well.
You can also have a model
dialog to show them,
this is where you want to go.
This is now the
place where you have
to install the full application
in order to continue
with the app's experience.
There is an API for that.
Basically, you check
whether you're running
in it in Instant App context.
And if you run it in
the Instant App context,
you show the install
prompt, which
gives you the install prompt
from the Play Store directly.
Let's take a look at
the next principle.
That's privacy and security.
One thing is the identity
of the user should
be easy for a user to log in.
So don't have them fumble
around with sign-up dialogs,
with long forms that they
actually have to sign in with,
and if they are new users, or
have them answer their password
and username.
If they're existing users, you
can use the Smart Lock APIs
for that to make sure that this
is as quick as possible and as
easy as possible for your users.
Also, for payments,
for in-app payments,
we already have the in-app
billing API available.
So you can use that for
digital goods, so everything
that you have within the
application or subscriptions
or anything like that.
It works with that.
But also, if you want to
ship something to the user
and have physical
goods available,
or you want to bring
the user somewhere,
then you use the
Google Payments API,
which uses the cards stored
in the Google user's account.
When it comes to
permissions, we make
sure that this is secure
for the users as well.
We reduced the amount
of available permissions
for Android Instant
Apps and the amount
of requestable permissions
depending on the API level.
So some of them are
available down to Lollipop,
and some of them are available
only from Android Oreo
and above.
So your Instant App could
run in a foreground service,
so this would be helpful for
media playing applications.
And it can read phone
numbers, which is
a subset of Read Phone State.
Well, be aware, with
background services,
they might be killed at
the system's convenience
when the user does not
really use the app anymore.
So as soon as the user decides
to switch to another app,
it can get and will
get evicted faster than
usually with installed apps.
When it comes to
local storage, you
want to probably
store data locally,
because you need to make sure
that you access all that.
And sometimes the user
comes back to the app,
and it's important to
actually have that available.
So we made it available to
the local private storage.
Also, there's a cache directory.
There is a cookie API
available, and you
can use the shared preferences,
as well as your database that's
already existing and
internal content providers.
But you don't get access
to external storage
or your exported
content providers.
That is, again, to make
sure that the users are
in a secure environment.
When it comes to migrating
user data from the Instant App
to the installed app, there,
we provided an API for that
as well, which relies on you
declaring the target sandbox
version 2 in your
installed application.
And how does it work?
That's the cookie API.
It's available to both
Instant App and installed app.
It allows you to store
and retrieve user data
when you migrate or as a
replacement for other ways
to store user data
that you already used.
How does it work?
It's, again, a
straightforward API.
You check whether the cookie
that you want to store
is small enough to
fit the cookie jar.
And then you update
your Instant App cookie.
The Instant App
cookie is a binary,
and it's available through both
the Package Manager as well
as the Support Package Manager.
On the other hand,
all you have to do
is get from the Package Manager.
Get back the internet
cookie, and then convert it
to the data that you already--
the data type that
you can work with.
And when you're done, you
can clean up after yourself
and clear the
Instant App cookie.
That is all I have to say on the
part of Instant App for today,
but there's a couple
of things that I
want you to keep in
mind when it comes to--
that I want you to keep in mind
when it comes to looking out
for Instant Apps.
One of the things is that
you probably want to go
to the g.co/InstantApps
or developer.androi
d.com/InstantApps.
Also, if you have questions,
post them on Stack Overflow,
and if you see that there
are samples missing,
or if you want to contribute
to samples for Android Instant
Apps, please file an
issue on Google Samples.
And there's also a couple
of other presentations
that are definitely highly
recommendable for Android
Instant Apps.
One of them is the Introduction
to Instant Apps, which
gives you more of a high level
overview of what they actually
are than this presentation.
Also, Building an
Android Instant App,
which takes you through
the modularization
process more hands-on than
this presentation as well.
Also, adding to that
is the Best Practices--
Slim Down Your App Size
session, which is really great
to get a great overview
of all the tools
that we've made
available for making sure
that your app size is
as small as possible
without sacrificing any
of your user's experience.
Thank you very much.
That's all for me.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]